President Trump calling on Democrats to
get back to work amid a standoff over
more cash for the paycheck paycheck
protection program
listen essentially we're waiting for 250
billion dollars the Democrats are
refusing to do it it's a small amount of
money relative to what it represents
because it represents small businesses
it represents them staying in business
it's something that should be approved
by the Democrats the Republicans want it
badly and the people wanted very badly
here not a reactive Democratic
congressman from New Jersey Josh got
himer congressman good morning to you
thanks for being here good morning
thanks for having me what's your take
what are you what's your reaction to
what the president just said well I
think we all want to get the Paycheck
program done and that's the loan
forgiveness program for small businesses
I've been talking about small businesses
day and night and we've got to stand by
them you know in New Jersey we've been
hit incredibly hard by the virus and I
think we're all on board you know there
are other issues that are also
critically important as you probably
know especially in those areas like
buying that have been hit so hard
between New York and New Jersey we've
got half the cases in the country and
you know our hospitals are really
struggling there at all resources and
our municipalities are our towns our
counties you know they're really tapped
out and need help in my district just to
give you a sense of it we've got 20,000
cases in my counties and and more than a
thousand people have died it's really a
very alarming situation here
respectfully congressman if everyone is
on board as you say why isn't it getting
done well my understanding is that
there's a lot of good conversation
happening Kevin McCarthy yesterday came
out and said that he thinks we've got a
deal so I'm hoping that it gets done I
mean there's you know there's no reason
why it's not getting done we've been
very good frankly about coming together
Democrats and Republicans to get the
first three packet emergency packages
done to help the country and help our
communities and we've got to get this
the Congress there is a reason it's not
getting done I mean we knew this was
gonna run out Republicans have been
calling from the beginning just
replenish this PPP program so small
businesses can get it yet Nancy Pelosi
in California is demanding other
spending in addition to it there's an
easy solution
why is your speaker holding out for
additional money well what's not I speak
for myself I don't you tell you that if
they held a vote I'm there and but but I
my point is we also need assurances in
the for the other areas where there are
serious crisis happening and in
districts like mine we've got to make
sure that we also take care of our
frontline health care workers and and as
you know it's real it's because you're
right in the area it's it's crushing our
states right now we need help not just
of course for our small businesses but
also for our frontline health care
workers for our hospitals and for arc
and for our towns so they're really in
tough trouble here congressman speaker
Pelosi wants obviously this additional
money for hospitals frontline health
care workers and then also for the
states and local governments who are
gonna have budget problems and
shortfalls here but that pressing issue
that peds just addressing there is the
reason why I'm getting emails many of us
in the news business are from business
owners saying I applied and now they're
saying you're not above they're not
gonna give you the low because I can't
apply anymore my question to you is take
me past Monday morning Tuesday when do
you see Congress taking action I believe
we're gonna get a deal done and I'm
hopefully gonna get a deal done this
weekend and we're gonna vote next week
that's that's where that's what I'm
hoping for it's what we're pushing for
have you been told you know I've been
told I mean I'm reading what you're
reading I'm not in the negotiation but I
know what we all believe strongly which
is we all have to get this done we all
represent these small businesses that
are in need I know I do and I'll tell
you it's a huge issue but one point on
why it's so important we get money to
our frontline health care workers who
are hospitals in our nursing homes in
the first in the cares Act that was
passed in New Jersey in my district
we're getting about six thousand dollars
in our hospitals per patient which would
cost would people in the hospital for
weeks and if you go to West Virginia
they're getting more than 400 thousand
dollars per patient just the way things
worked out so you can see why some areas
are getting crushed and what we need to
do is put the resources where the where
you've got a hurricane hitting right and
that's that's what we've always done
when there's a natural disaster we try
to help out the areas that are
hurt most whether that's our local
communities and our first responders or
our frontline health care workers we've
got to make sure we stand by them and I
think that's what you know I'm not
hearing everybody understand that in the
country and I think it's really
important they understand what what some
of our communities are going through
well we're gonna stand by the hope that
this does get done as you know you're
suggesting in the meantime you were
named to president Trump's bipartisan
task force that's focused on reopening
the economy where do we stand with that
I mean I know New York New Jersey this
area some of the hardest hit places in
the country what is it going to take to
get every one do you think into this
phase one I know it's gonna be you know
incremental for different states no we
talked about this with the president
what's what's critically important is
that we need a back to work checklist as
that were way to come reopen America and
reopen communities like like mine at in
a safe and healthy way and we you know
as we're we're dealing with the economic
with the health crisis we've also got to
deal with the economic crisis and make
sure to the point on the making sure our
small businesses are taken care of we
need a clear checklist for how you
reopen what needs to be in place of
course testing essential to that and if
we don't have we just don't have enough
testing here and every day I'm on the
phone just like I'm gonna phone with our
businesses I'm on the phone with our
frontline health care workers and and
with others we're saying and first
responders saying please I need a test
and we're really struggling to get those
tests we also need to make sure that our
hospitals have what they need so if
there was an outbreak again that we
could handle it you know that's the
protective equipment it's ventilators
everything that needs to be in line and
you know so there's a lot and also very
clear instructions with how we operate
our businesses you know what's safe you
know how do we make sure we keep people
healthy in this process so there's
there's got to be a very clear checklist
we've got a co-chair a group called the
problem solvers caucus we've got a
checklist we're putting out of what we
think needs to be in place to reopen but
but I just say this we just got to do it
in a safe in a safe way Congress said
you as you mentioned you're in one of
the hardest hits areas we're thinking
about the residents there president said
yesterday safety first that's critically
important but as we learn more we also
know who's affected we also know who the
vulnerable populations are so as we
learn that information within that
context even in some of the harder hit
areas isn't there room for some latitude
for healthy people who want to take the
proper safety precautions to go
while and open their business up as long
as they practice the social distancing
and are responsible about it listen
that's that's among the guidelines we're
looking for and obviously the people
like the CDC are smarter than than I am
on this and tell us exactly what we can
do to keep people safe I think a key
part of that is you probably would agree
is testing you have to be able to know
that if someone has it or doesn't have
it because there's carriers and you
don't want to find out that you're
suddenly spreading it all over again and
we've got to close down the country I
mean one again that my biggest fear
would be that we reopen and that it
spreads again we've got to shut it down
they'll be devastating to the economy
and devastating to the country that so
badly wants to open so I think you've
got to do it in smart phases you've got
to think of course regionally and you
have to think in a smart way by industry
but listen I want to make sure that we
can do everything we can to reopen
quickly I want the kids go back to
school we all want to get out of the
house but we've got to make sure as the
president said yesterday that we do it
in a very safe way representative Josh
Scott heimer thank you you're in the
middle of it literally figuratively in
Washington good luck thank you for
joining us on the rover everyone okay
thank you so much thank you very much